du nouveau pour la carte scolaire les
parents vont désormais avoir plus de
choix pour inscrire leur enfant en
sixième ce que ce que prévoient une
circulaire publiée aujourd'hui par le
ministère de l'éducation
nous allons avoir le détail avec lauren
cuisine un instant je vous rappelle que
jusqu'à présent les enfants sont
automatiquement affectés dans un
établissement qui dépend de leur lieu
d'habitation l'expérience conduite ces
dernières années qui conclut en
d'ailleurs dans 11 départements va
pouvoir s'étendre maintenant à 74
départements ça concerne 520 collège et
par ici mais également lorraine cusin
hervé onze ans entre en sixième en
septembre élèves d'une école primaire du
20e a paris il pourra aller dans trois
collèges du quartier celui du secteur de
son domicile ou deux autres très voisins
les auxquels ils n'auraient pu accéder
librement jusqu alors ses parents
entendent bien profiter de cette
possibilité de choix si je regarde les
trois établissements qui me sont
proposées
il y en a un qui est quand même plus
proche du domicile
ce qui lui permettra quand même d'être
plus rapidement l'école d'être plus tôt
à la maison à la sortie
et la deuxième
ma deuxième préoccupation c'est de lui
voir
casser ses habitudes depuis la
maternelle il a pratiquement les mêmes
camarades et il a plutôt tendance à se
laisser entraîner bon ça nous arrive
d'avoir le soir des
petits mots sur les carnets de
correspondance à ce sujet là dans ce
quartier comme pour la plupart des
expériences les parents pour opter entre
2 à 5 établissements un choix encore
limitée quatre arrondissements concernés
à paris et sur toute la france à peine
10% des collèges et bien souvent les
établissements les plus réputés sur des
exclus des secteurs de libre choix bref
une opération prudente des marrons
certains certains départements ont
conduit des expériences les années
précédentes
c'est la première fois que nous
commençons à paris notre but est bien de
dire la vérité et n'est pas de laisser
laisser croire que le
le choix un choix absolu il va être
possible nous serons obligés de tenir
compte des capacités d'accueil des
structures des établissements et des
contraintes qui existe pas question donc
de voir certains collèges se vidèrent au
profit d'autres si un établissement est
trop demander une commission locale
composée de l'inspecteur de parents des
chefs d'établissement et d'élus définira
les critères d'affectation jamais les
notes de l'enfant ne devront être un
critère reste un problème comment les
familles vont-elles s'informer
objectivement
le bouche à oreille est pour beaucoup
dans le choix des établissements les
parents discutent entre eux et william
il ya des rumeurs qui existent la
réputation réputation et ça c'est quand
même regrettable
les parents désirent une information
plus transparente
certains souhaiteraient même qu'on
procède à une évaluation des collèges de
son côté le ministère pour l'instant
ainsi que les établissements à mieux se
faire connaître
là haut